Alright Charles, let's, let's figure this one out. It turns out,
as I said, there's lots of different ways to make this work,
but, what we're going to do is move that line that we had
for conjunction. If we, what we really want to do now is figure
out how to move it down ,so that now, these three points,
are, in the green zone. They're going to output, one, because they're the
or, and the only one in the, that's left in the zero
zone in the, in the red zone is the zero, zero case.
>> Right.
>> So, How are we going to be able to do that?
>> Well, since ,we want it to be case that, either,
X2 or X1, being one get you above the line, then, we need a threshold
and a set of weights ,that put either one of them over. You
don't have to have both of them, you only need one of them.
>> Okay.
>> So, let's imagine a case where X1 is one
and X2 is zero ,then basically, oh, there you're right,
there's a whole lot of answers, so a weight
of 1, for X1, would give you a one. Right?
>> Yes, Huh
>> And so, if we made the threshold 1, that would work.
>> What about weight 2?
>> Well, we do exactly the same thing. So, we set, weight 2 equal to 1.
And that means, that in the case where both of them are 0, you get 0 plus 0,
which gives you something less than 1. If ,one of them
is 1 and the other is 0, you get 1, which
gives you right at the threshold. And, if both of them,
are, one then you get two, which is still greater than one.
>> Good, alright, that seems like it worked. The other
way we could do it, is we can keep the weights
at in another way we can do it, is keep
the weights where they were before, that just moves this line
nice and smoothly down. And then, right? So
before, we had a, a threshold of, one
and a half. Now we need a threshold of, like, a half ,ought to do it.
>> Yep.
>> Or even less, as long as it's greater
than zero. So, a quarter should work, as well.
>> So, good, so, lots, lots of different ways
to do that. And, cool. Can we do not?
>> What's not of two variables?
>> That's a good question.
Let's do not of one variable, then.
>> Okay.